we begin with breaking news out of Hong
Kong which has reported its first death
from the coronavirus it's the second
fatality from the virus outside of
mainland China well on Monday Hong Kong
closed ten of its 13 borders with
mainland China in a bid to stop the
spread of the virus but medical workers
have been demanding that the border be
completely shut
well 425 people are now known to have
died from the virus within China and
there's more than 20,000 confirmed cases
the virus is continuing to spread
elsewhere with more than 150 cases
confirmed in 23 countries we'll Adrian
brown joins us live now from Hong Kong
Adrian so confirmation then that one man
in the territory has died from the virus
what more can you tell us well according
to Hong Kong officials that this man was
39 and he was the man responsible for
the first person-to-person transmission
here in Hong Kong which was confirmed on
Monday evening the other person being
his mother now the person who has died
had an underlying condition which is
also the case with many other people
who've been dying on the mainland so
outside of the mainland this is the
second person to have died from the
virus the other case being in the
Philippines now all this happened daran
just hours after caralyn the chief
executive of Hong Kong announced she was
shutting down more of Hong Kong's border
with China behind me is the bridge to
China that is still open one of three
links to the outside world that his
remaining open the other being the
International Airport and another
crossing point
nearby at Shenzhen Bay now Carrie Lam of
course has been under mounting pressure
to close all of the border she says
she's not going to do that because to do
so would be to go against the guidelines
of the World Health Organization
there's also another important factor
Daren there are plenty of people who
live in Hong Kong Berger across the
border every day to the city of Shenzhen
where they work and then come back again
in the evening on Sunday up to a hundred
thousand people went backwards and
forwards across this border most of them
were Hong Kong Chinese citizens
also have to remember of course that
Hong Kong is is reliant on the mainland
for things like vegetables and milk that
has to be trucked in every day so there
are practical reasons also says the
chief executive for making sure that the
frontier in parts remains open an
Adrienne it's day two of that medical
workers strike with doctors and nurses
expected to join tell us what's been
happening well there is a protest taking
place at the moment outside the hospital
Authority which is responsible for more
than 40 of Hong Kong's public hospitals
the strike appears to be gaining
momentum on Monday around about two and
a half thousand doctors and nurses
decided to stay home not to work that
meant that a number of operations had to
be cancelled including cancer patients
now it seems that more doctors and
nurses have joined this action that of
course is of deepening concern to the
chief executive Carrie Lam and she's
been speaking about the actions of the
doctors this morning and once more
saying that her priority is the health
of the Hong Kong people let's listen to
what she had to say I certainly would
not agree with the allegation that we
are sort of not addressing this public
health concern adequately and certainly
I don't agree with the allegation that
we are putting politics above for public
health this is a public health situation
and we are assisted by our experts and
both external and in house to tackle
this very important situation and Daren
I just want to update you on the
situation in Wuhan on Tuesday morning
one of those hospitals which is being
assembled in record time to accept
patients has now begun accepting
patients around about 50 have been
admitted to that mobile hospital and
other three hospitals of course are also
under construction and on Monday night
there was an important meeting of the
Politburo Standing Committee this is the
most powerful body in all of China of
course it includes the Chinese President
Xi Jinping and that body made a rare
mission saying there had been
deficiencies and shortcomings in the way
that China had responded to the
emergency and said that those officials
who had failed would be punished and
said that China really had to improve
the way that it responded to national
emergencies in the future so that sort
of language very rare indeed Daren or
it's Adrian Brown there in Hong Kong
Adrian thank you